les forces policières sont aux aguets à
Pékin tandis que Shanghai des barrières
ont été installées la Chine anticipe
d'autres manifestations comme celles qui
ont secoué le pays ces derniers jours
la colère contre le président semble
atteindre des sommets
[Applaudissements]
un incendie mortel dans la province du
signe Jang à milfo au poudre des Chinois
estiment que la politique zéro covid de
Pékin a ralenti les secours et demande
un relâchement des mesures sanitaires
il y a pas eu de manifestation de cet
ampleur là dans autant de villes depuis
je dirais les événements de juin 1989
alors qu'il y avait eu le massacre à la
place Tianan
plus démocratique que des autres régions
en Chine cette montréalaise arrivée au
pays en 2014 a grandi à Shanghai où elle
était journaliste elle affirme n'avoir
jamais vu de manifestations du genre
dans sa ville natale je pense que c'est
très nouveau pro des Chinois qui est
fait manifester dans la rue ceux qui
comme elle veulent visiter de la famille
en Chine doivent se soumettre à
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
d'isolement si bien qu'elle a abandonné
l'idée d'y aller pour l'instant on ne
comprend pas pourquoi
les autres pays on a déjà fait la
règlement différent pour le Corvette
mais en Chine on est encore insisté que
il faut vraiment
zéro combien d'autant plus que les
restrictions pèsent sur l'économie
chinoise l'économie va mal le personnel
immobilier c'est tout ça mais ensemble
fait que si une pink se retrouve devant
une tempête presque parfaite Pékin ne
guère d'autres choix que de faire des
concessions croient cette expert mais je
pense pas que en passant je pense pas
que ça va amener un changement de
régiment il faut s'entendre parce que il
y a pas d'alternative politique aux
parties communistes n'empêche la grogne
est désormais impossible à ignorer ici
Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada MONT